in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jason
and Amanda are with us hey guys how are
you guys are you better than I deserve
welcome welcome so you're here to do
your debt free scream yes we are where
are you from we're from wodsworth Ohio
which is about 40 minutes south of
Cleveland okay woah a bit of a halt in
Nashville yes for the coaching classes
Oh perfect timing okay good good so how
much debt have you paid off we've paid
off a hundred and forty-one thousand
dollars congratulations how long did a
took us three and a half years
very good making what kind of money we
started at 77,000 and we're now at 115
whoa nice increase what happened to
cause that well I got a different job
I'm working in insurance now and Jason
got a promotion he's now an engineering
manager way to go guys things are
cooking well done well done
so what god that was this hundred and
forty-one thousand mostly student loans
yeah Wow 20 was student loans and 21 was
car debt
so Sallie Mae had you in a headlock yeah
so three and a half years ago you looked
up and went you ugly old woman I'm
kicking you out of my life what happened
how did what made you decide to do this
my mom actually wanted to put us through
the through FPU and you know at the time
we were making our payments we you know
but it was kind of like okay mom well
you know we'll do it just to make mom
happy and you know we got through the
class and you know we didn't come out of
the class super fired up but as we
started to see it work you know I
remember thinking wow we just paid our
cars off that you know we had five-year
loans on our cars and we just paid them
off and you know like six months apiece
you know and it was like this is working
so and once it starts working you get
more fired up then yeah it sort of
turned into a game you know what else
could we cut where else can we save you
know so when you start to believe you're
willing to sacrifice that yeah yeah but
until you start to believe you're like
I'm gonna test this a little air but
then when they hope when the hope kicks
in you can see the finish line you can
turn
on a sprint of the line yeah absolutely
yes very cool very cool
so Amanda what is the secret when people
hear you've paid off a hundred and
forty-one thousand dollars in debt and
now you're a newly graduated coach from
the Dave Ramsey School here so what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is I think a couple things I
think budgeting absolutely you have to
be on the same page and have that budget
every month every month is different so
I'm just making sure that we went
through and and did our budget unique to
that month and then also communication
so being on the same page and you know
it's much easier to make those cuts in
the budget and sacrifice when you're on
the same page and you're doing it
together mm-hmm so it's impossible when
you're not doing it together absolutely
yeah
so what was the biggest budget fight you
guys had in that three and a half years
I think we didn't have any major you
know knockdown drag-outs but y'all are
just too nice I think the biggest
disagreement was was stopping our
contribute contributions to the 401 K
she was ready to do that and I I wasn't
but once she finally convinced me you
know I kind of understood no and now
it's you feel it differently you know I
was like we don't need the lights on we
can turn the thermostat down
we don't you know and you look up three
and a half years later and one hundred
and forty-one thousand dollars is gone
yeah but you probably kind of felt like
it was never gonna go away it in you yes
it felt like it was gonna take forever
and actually you know the biggest loan
was Sallie Mae and so we created this
chart on the front of our refrigerator
that was the death of the Sallie Mae
alone right there and that was our
momentum to keep going I love it well
that's awesome
very cool so now that you're at the end
of it do you remember the first time you
sat down and did the budget and looked
at this thing and you could see I mean
you're standing at the base of this
mountain really going we got to climb
this mountain was it harder
at the now that you look back on it or
easier than you thought it was gonna be
when you started I think it was a little
bit easier than than what we thought
because when we first started we didn't
really know like I didn't know what I
spent on groceries I just went to the
grocery store and bought stuff you know
so we we just had no idea what we were
spending on stuff each month and so we
were just totally off track and it just
I feel like it just got easier as it
went on because you know we like he said
we've kind of made a game out of it we
would say you know okay how much can we
cut in groceries and still be able to
eat like you know let's see can we go
this low and get in cash out you put it
in our envelopes and you know kind of do
that so as a coach when you're sitting
down with someone in the future and they
feel overwhelmed and they feel like I
won't it I mean I see what you're saying
we need to do but you know you can look
at them and tell them the truth is it's
easier than it looks right now yes
absolutely and giving themselves some
grace and just knowing that you know
where they are right now doesn't have to
be where they're gonna end up and that
they you know they're they'll get
through it so well congratulations you
two very very well done thank you Jason
and Amanda Cleveland Ohio a hundred and
forty-one thousand dollars paid off in
three and a half years making seventy
seven now making 115 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one word
love it love it love it very well done
you two
absolutely fabulous